good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters I
asked for brief questions and of course
I got them beginning briefs or boxers I
wear boxer briefs let's move on if
everybody stopped sneezing how long do
you think it would take somebody to
realize it well I don't know I guess I'm
gonna say like a month but I'd like to
see some rigorous research applied to
the question it's a very interesting one
I think it would take a little while for
people to be like hey have you sneezed
recently because I haven't how do you
think having children has impacted your
writing I guess there are a lot of times
when 2009 we would have been writing in
2015 me is making a Lego Wookiee gunship
but I got to say I don't really feel
like it's a bad change I mean this thing
holds two different wookies it has
double wookie pilots a girl of my school
told me she'd rather be popular than
smart what is the correct response to
this hmm
sympathy hey John what's your middle
name danger it's not it's Michael last
TV show you marathon the Americans which
is excellent 'are you writing another
book
you know another awesome thing about
this wookie gunship it opens up its got
like a cargo bay inside of it who's a
relatively unknown poet you love there's
a lot but the first who comes to mind is
the persian poet Hafiz so if you like is
not as well known here as he should be
apart from pizza what do you think is
the best no no no no no dinner there is
no apart from pizza not a lot things in
this world that make me angry but you
should not be apart from pizza alright I
apologize for the seriousness but that's
something I feel strongly about let's
return to lighter questions
hey I heard they're making Looking for
Alaska into a movie who are you gonna
cast it I don't cast movie adaptations
of my books are actually any movies say
will you cast Katie hell yeah I just
don't cast movies I'm a novelist and a
video blogger and a pizza enthusiast and
not a caster of film say when are you
gonna do your inkless tattoo punishment
soon ish maybe you should get done i
don't cast movies tattooed on my cheek
no that's a bad idea even for an inquest
tattoo but I do need a tattoo idea let
me know if you have any in comments if
you could choose one dinosaur to ride
onto its back into battle what dinosaur
would it be hey Henry I have a Dino
question for you apparently we're gonna
go with Apatosaurus hey now that you're
back home what project are you most
excited to work on well we still haven't
put the wings on I think they like flap
it's going to be awesome when it's
finished
also I'm signing my name over and over
again so that independent bookstores
around the US will have signed copies of
Paper Towns for the holidays hey I
didn't see your cameo in the Paper Towns
movie
that's not something you see so much is
it's someone you hear and finally do you
think you or Hank would get further in
American Ninja Warrior Henry and I have
been watching a lot of American Ninja
Warrior so I have a built-in advantage
because I at least know what it is
whereas I suspect Hank doesn't I
actually like my odds to get past the
quintuple steps yeah I'm gonna say me
Hank maybe we can add American Ninja
Warrior to next year's quadriga Khan in
the meantime I will see you on Friday
wait I forgot to answer the most asked
question of the week can we see Willie
well a trait hi Omar Baba